le raid l'élite de la police des super
agent surentraîné leur devise servir
sans faillir toujours à ces pour le
secrétariat l'infirmerie où la cantine
je suis là pour le groupe d'intervention
du raid
c'est un danger pour le veau une
mauvaise et une femme froissart ça crie
ça chiale ça se fête les ondes ça se
passe les cheveux dans le casque bon on
a une femme c'est comme ça non puis ça a
tout le temps envie de pisser
on n'a pas les combinaisons adapté pour
les pisseuses effectivement vous n'êtes
pas du tout match je me suis trompé
vous êtes 16 il ya quatre lits par
chambre est faite moi tout de suite 4
groupes de 4 c au greffe
alors ça c'est un groupe de 16 j'ai
parcouru son dossier elle a de très
grande qualité à ses nerfs se cacher et
le fait qu'elle porte le même nom
camilli de l'intérieur mais ça n'a rien
à voir
c'est sa fille mais ça n'a aucun rapport
je vous préviens la première occasion de
l'avenir
il faut aller la chercher là non je vous
regarde le fait encore de gueule
[Musique]
pardon halal est éliminé à la banon
l'ennemi est neutralisée là
[Musique]